استانفت الرحلات الجويه بين مطري جده
واربيل العراقيه حيث سجل مطار اربيل
الدوليه اليوم اقلاع اول رحله الى مدينه
جده بواسطه طيران السعودي فلايناس ل 172
مسافرا بين معتمر وسائح حيث سيكون جدول
الرحلات مسجل بواقع رحلتين اسبوعيا من
مطري اربيل وجده وبالعكس كمرحله اولى
معنى الان من داخل مطار اربيل مراسل
العربيه احمد الحمداني اهلا بك يا احمد
معنا احمد كيف تسير اذا يعني اول رحله تم
تسييرها كيف كانت يعني ما هي الخطط
المستقبليه والاستئناف الرحلات ايضا
طبعا قبل اكثر من نصف ساعه بقليل تم اقلاع
الطائره متوجه الى مطار مطار جده وان هي
الرحله الاولى الرسميه ما بين العراق
والسعوديه
بعد ثلاث عقود على ما يبدو من القطيعه وان
طبعا
طبعا كان هناك صحيح ان في في موسم الحج
تسير العراق رحلات جويه لكنها ليست دائميه
فقط لموسم الحج بالتالي فان اول رحله
رسميه اقلعت
وستكون بحسب بحسب القنصليه السعوديه
باربيل التي حضرت حضرت
طبعا مع مع تغطيه اعلاميه كبيره
لهذا هذا الحدث الذي يعتبر حدث مهم جدا
وقالوا لي انهم انهم يسعون الى ان يكون
هناك ايضا رحلات على غرار اربيل جده من
مطار بغداد الدولي بالتالي فان الاولى
المطار او الاولى الرحلات
نظمت من مطار اربيل الدولي لاسباب عده
ذكرتها القنصليه السعوديه منها ان
البروتوكولات والاتفاقيات كانت ما بين
بدايه اربيل جده ومن ثم ستكون مع بين
بغداد وجده او بقيه مطارات المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بالتالي فان انتهت او
اقلعت الرحله وستكون
الاستئناف هذه الرحلات عوده من مطار جدا
دلاله استئناف هذه الرحلات بدايه من اربيل
وربما بعد ذلك من بغداد الى السعوديه عوده
العلاقات بشكل
تام بين السعوديه والعراق
بالتاكيد عوده العلاقات التدريجيه منذ
فتره ليست بالقصيره ما بين بين الرياض
وبغداد وما بين طبعا بالتالي يكون هناك
الامر يسحب الى اربيل ووجود سفارات
متبادله وايضا القنصليه في اربيل وهذا
طبعا كان قبل ايام كورونا جائحه كورونا هي
من اجلت هذه المشاريع كان هناك مشاريع عام
2020 في افتتاح مطارات وما الى ذلك من
مشاريع استراتيجيه اقتصاديه بين الطرفين
لكن عام 2020 والاغلاق العام في كل دول
العالم تسبب
بتاجيل مشاريع استراتيجيه ضمن اتفاقيات ما
بين بغداد الرياض من ضمنها الرحلات الجويه
وايضا المباشره
وليس فقط في موسم الحج ولكن في رحلات
منظمه وطبعا كان هناك فرح كبير من قبل
المسافرين الذين اتقيتهم وقالوا لي انهم
بفرح كبير لاول مره لا يستخدمون ترانزيت
او واسطه مطارات اخرى عمان او مصر كانوا
قبل قبل يعني قبل
الان كان الان اصبح
الرحلات مباشره الى مطار جده وبالتالي
احرموا من هنا من مطار اربيل وراحوا
المعتمرين ذهبوا الى مطار جده ساعتين او
ساعتين ونصف يقولون هناك بالتالي فان ردات
فعل
ايجابيه جدا بين المسافرين الذين طبعا
واجهوا او واجهوا صعوبات كبيره طوال عقود
ثلاث عقود من المعاناه للمسافر والمعتمر
والحاج العراقي في في هذه في هذا البلد